this series of interlocking shapes is a
new kind of material what we created is
a new fabric designed on a computer and
3d printed very much inspired by the
medieval chainmail with some amazing
properties which can be tuned from being
soft and foldable to being stiff and
rigid
dario and her team had a very specific
idea for a new kind of smart fabric we
really wanted to make a materials that
came can change stiffness on command and
we were thinking about solutions for
example for
wearable medical devices think about for
example supports or exoskeletons
that when needed they could become rigid
like a cast to provide support or
protection to the weather and for
inspiration they turned to coffee if you
think about coffee grains
when they are unpacked and loose uh
coffee grains they can be poured like a
liquid however coffee grains when you
buy them sometimes they are vacuum
packed and when they're packed they're
really stiff and rigid like a brick this
change in properties is a kind of phase
transition from flexible or flowing to
stiff and rigid and it happens when the
individual particles jam together
how stiff the final material is depends
on the shapes of the particles and how
much they can touch each other when you
have two grains of coffee they can only
touch at one point so that's a single
point of contact and this is a classical
example of convex shapes they can only
touch at a point however if one of the
particles for example is concave
like a
crescent moon
then you can imagine that two adjacent
particles could interpenetrate more
tightly or fit more snugly with one
another think about the pieces of a
puzzle kiara's team designed a series of
complex 3d particles that could be made
to interlock connecting at multiple
points
the idea is that the more contact there
is between them the more solidly they
can jam together
when compressed in a vacuum bag the
material becomes stiff enough to support
over a kilogram of weight
the precise properties of this kind of
material could be tailored to specific
applications we could replace these
materials with other for example stiffer
materials like aluminum or steel and you
could also think about making these
particles much larger for
deployable architectural structures like
emergency bridges or shelters though
vacuum packing might not always be the
most practical way of changing the
fabric's properties we are for example
exploring alternative solutions for
compressing or jamming particles that
include
external fields like
magnetic attraction between adjacent
particles or tension created by fibers
and pulleys that could be interwoven
in the hollow space within the particles
those
actuated either by a small motor or
for example in response to external
stimuli like temperature ph or light
there's a long way to go but this smart
fabric could be the next link in the
chain towards tunable materials